ce que je vends dit que c'est moi le
problème est de le temps d'en avoir rien
à [ __ ] de croyances des gens ou de
leur religion c'est tout simplement un
petit con
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sarah fresu que j'aime bien ça
voilà voilà qu'il est toujours venue
elle est toujours été très gentil après
voilà je suis pas d'accord avec elle sur
un an mais je les aime bien mais voilà
donc mais vous avez le droit de dire ce
que vous pensez
elle a fait la promotion de produits
pour raffermir son vagin maman tu perds
je savais pas que ça se raffermissait
elle perd la filme que salah cela
permettrait d'éviter la tromperie
puisque à mon avis sa technique en fait
c'est que de s'enfermer ensuite mes
[Rires]
confidences de femmes par exemple qui me
disent bah écoute mon mari m'a trompé
parce que ça ne va plus on y est c'est
vrai que en fait on n'en parle pas assez
et surtout qu'on vous propose pas assez
de produits naturels qui pourrait vous
aider faut savoir et les meufs que déjà
je vais vous montrer les produits donc
là c'est des capsules de resserrement
intime donc c'est assez pour resserrer
vos parties d'un t-il mais il existe
quand même des capsules de resserrement
intimes
vous avez jamais utilisée non
mais tu signes facile aussi vous faites
ça mais moi je voulais le faire dans lé
psg chez des week ends
[Applaudissements]
s'il n'y a pas de danger pour la santé
c'est papy c'est pas non c'est pas plus
méchant que si un influenceur me
prescrit bdd des pilules pour impôts
pour l'érection par exemple mathieu au
centre en fait autant aucune morale non
seulement ces bêtes c'est dangereux et
c'est irresponsable c'est dans son jeu
qu'est-ce que dans sa mère parce qu'en
fait on sait que tu l'air chez les
jeunes qui vont à regarder d'accord et
elle elle dit mais voit sa dangereuse à
tromper car c'est ma piaule
sous-entendez parce que j'ai un vagin ou
caylar abdallah saleh ça veut dire que
c'est une incitation à la pédophilie
vous savez là je vais là où je vais déjà
[Applaudissements]
faire des régimes bad est tout à fait
clasher des meccanos merci c'est un
hommage elle se contente quand tu dis
que tu sois disant qu'une jeune fille de
12 ans alain d'agen comme il faut ça
sous-entend que quand à 30 ans tape un
vagin comme il faut ça veut dire que
quelque part tu as ça te format que le
cerveau et sa troupe le 26 mai à par
rapport aux garçons aujourd'hui qu'ils
vont justement cherché des filles de
plus en plus jeunes avec une jarre simon
avec des ballons
qu'on embrasse on a mission
seulement alors oui alors
terminé la chose qui me dérange c'est
que j'ai pas d'enfants mais si j'avais
une fille de 10 ans il dit tomber sur ce
genre de vidéos ça me met très mal à
l'aise pour moi et pour ma fille et elle
n'a pas besoin de savoir ça c'est plus
tard quand quand elle sera adulte et
c'est pas des choses qu'on dit à des
enfants si votre fille et le maillot
violet raison d'autres que c'est bien qu
allissa par exemple ce ma fille ça se
lit pas sarah frioux et si la seule
presse qu'elle suisse et tagada
camille n'est pas ça la raison kenny
hallaert la cerec le message envoyé aux
femmes c'est quoi votre mari vous
trouvez en fait c'est de votre faute
l'agencé a eu un terrible on
al'impression moi j'ai rien j'ai rien
contre a été mis là la seule à faire
c'est mon impression que les
influenceurs aujourd'hui contre un peu
d'argent et que vous
commettez kate moss sur un magazine qui
était tout film pareil on complique et
les femmes qui étaient
jamais le dit que le jeune quitte au
coeur qui avaient tous marqué en europe
dans une église a voulu réitérer
cette fois ci c'est dans une mosquée qui
l'a imaginé faire sa vidéo aujourd'hui
je vais partir à la recherche d'une
mosquée à paris manque de chance ou de
culture le jeune homme s'est en réalité
rendu devant l'église orthodoxe de la
sainte trinité à paris au quai j'ai
trouvé une mosquée
le lieu est enfermé benjamin rebrousser
chemin et les internautes ne sont pas
restés indifférents face à cette
nouvelle tentative de provocation parce
que je suis pas partisan de
si tu veux la paix tac à t'excuser
takada excusé je suis c'est comme la
posture dans laquelle on a toujours misé
sur ce plateau ou par les médias ou ou
sur les réseaux j'ai tout était dans la
posture de l'accusé de celui que j'avais
fait quelque chose de mal de celui qui
avait commis un crime et je pense pas
que j'en ai commis bien et je pense que
j'ai plus envie de
deux coups ne demande pas enfin je
demande le père de ma personne je veux
pas perdre on je devrais le pas fin vous
voulez continuer à provoquer je pense
pas que des provocations directes mais
je ne revient pas en arrière et cherche
pas à combinant momo par respect je veux
laisser la parole d'abord à la baie la
chorale ici l'abbé de la morandais moi
je suis venu pour chercher à campbon
voilà comme nous a quand même
c'est exactement ça pourquoi que
fonctionne comme ça tu as des comptes à
régler benjamin j'ai pas trouvé réglé je
suis plutôt un pourquoi pas pourquoi pas
non mais oui c'est ce que je leur dis
que c'est vrai blasphème et de le
tourner en avoir rien à [ __ ] de des
croyances des gens ou de la religion
mais il est considéré en tant que
personne mais ce qu'a dit la vélo on l'a
dit la liberté s'arrête là où bat wee cc
et momo toi ça te dérange et c'est moi
en tant que croyant forcément je suis
choqué que ce soit dans une église une
synagogue ou ou dans une mosquée je suis
forcément ça me choque autant croyant
parce que je sais que derrière tout ça
il ya des croyants ça peut aussi heurté
des millions par des milliers de
personnes restent à lui dire ce soir
benjamin moi j'ai juste envie de lui
dire ça un discours de grand frère que
j'ai envie de l'avoir inclus c'est pas
un discours de ces pas un discours de
deux je vais te mettre une baffe ou quoi
ou non il faut que tu saches un truc
faut que tu saches faut que tu saches un
truc benjamin si tu veux visité deux
mosquées étaient toujours bien venues tu
seras toujours le bienvenu mais il ya
des règles à respecter il faut de la
pudeur du respect il humilie tais toi si
tu arrives à avoir ces trois qualités en
toi viens je te prend la main on y va
tous les deux et c'est pas forcément ce
que tu vois la télé les musulmans non
j'ai pas juste mais moi mais moi en tant
que s'il veut il s'en fout de la vie ces
changements fou du respect de la
religion et il s'en fout de tout en fait
quand vous êtes sur les réseaux sociaux
vous incarnez un personnage qui est
constamment dans la provocation quand
vous venez sur ce plateau c'est pour
plaire minnerath parce qu'il vendait
plus visible
[Applaudissements]
ces vidéos un cours vous nous dites que
ces vidéos c'est pour dénoncer non jésus
vous nous dites que c'est pour faire du
buzz donc j'ai une question est-ce que
vous avez par action demandé
la question
il faut que je donne des justifications
à personne chez les tiges en avait juste
rien à [ __ ] de la religion est
justement le respect se doit danser le
blasphème j'ai le droit d'inventaire
supportable et puis le temps qu'on le
reçoit il raconte n'importe quoi ils
n'arrêtent pas de mentir c'était
c'est tout simplement un petit con et
c'est à supporter
[Applaudissements]
c'est évidemment je suis tellement
désolé pas pour faire en deux séparés
l'un de l'autre bah oui mais non je suis
désolé
pour
rien après tout c'est extrêmement gentil
et politiquement correct depuis le début
qu'on les reçoit oui si tout le monde
était délicieux mais j'aimerais correct
mais du coup c'est ma maison tu fais que
c'était le lendemain il recommençait
vas-y sa venue mais vous allez y aller
dans une mosquée je crois pas donc ça va
y aller pourquoi pas avec la prochaine
vidéo ce sera toi je vais te dire à moi
tu sais benjamin schmidt avait défendu
la première fois effectivement là je
pense qu on a créé un monstre mais sauf
que effectivement tu es content en fait
parce que ces entretiens le monde en
fait et le monstre se goinfrer se
nourrit de ce qu'il est en train de
créer et en fait moi j'ai peur pour toi
parce que je pense que tu es
complètement perdu tu es complètement
perdition t en donnant chypre était en
danger pour toi mais je le pense moi
comme une maman tu as tu as l'âge de mon
fils donc je me permets de te le dire
pardon mais à chaque fois tu remets une
pièce dans la machine et à chaque fois
tu reviens sur tes pmp à chaque fois tu
dis quelque chose de différent à chaque
fois tu troni tu dis d'abord celle du
cynisme la presse et nironi après c'est
autre chose en fait tu es complètement
poney là je vous le dis avec tout mon
coeur fait attention à moi ou quoi
arrêté pour vous protéger pour protéger
alors il ya des gens qui lisent sur les
réseaux dessus qu'on lui donne de la
force en invitant qu'est ce que vous
avez à répondre à ça j'ai rallumé j'ai
dit qu'on avait créé un monstre on est
brillant mais tous à ceux ci chez moi
j'ai pas si on lui donne de la force et
moi je suis choquée qu'au bout de quatre
émissions sur marc germain ya encore des
gens comme gide qui tombent dans le
panneau et qui arrive à le défendre mais
il s'est fait bloquer je suis pas tant
le fait l'objet
bernard montiel il pleurniche on dira je
les reçois des menaces 2009 sur une
vidéo et wav devant bernard montiel
cesser son nom
[Musique]
ce qu'on vient d'apprendre la
disparition d'un ami d'un ami vraiment
très cher de tpm p2 vous de tous les
français d'ailleurs la disparition de
notre jean pierre pernaut voilà qu'on
aime on revoit son sourire là c'est vrai
que et tout cela on serait on se
rappelle de lui voilà de tous les
souvenirs qu'on a pu vivre avec lui
c'était vraiment un des personnages que
j'ai mis le plus à la télévision qui
était toujours là pour aider pour donner
des conseils pour parler vraiment à tout
le monde y parle à tout le monde il
était sympa avec tout le monde et c'est
vrai que c'est une légende de la
télévision qui nous quitte c'est la
dernière pour moi énorme star de l'info
voilà c'était pour moi même la plus
grande star de l'info je les ai toujours
dit ici et c'est vrai que là on est tous
très très triste on a vu bernard il ya
un instant qui a dû l'annoncer dans le 6
à 7 en direct et c'est vrai qu'on savait
depuis quelques jours que jean-pierre
voilà vivait des moments difficiles et
voilà on se disait jean-pierre il est
immortel 1 il a survécu a énormément
énormément de choses et on l'attendait
voilà de le revoir on attendait tous de
le revoir et c'est vrai que pour nous il
sera il sera toujours là à jamais et on
pense forcément à toute sa famille qui
sont des très proches aussi de notre
équipe un atelier à ses enfants et voilà
on leur dit qu'on les aime fort qu'on
sera là pour eux bien sûr est que
jean-pierre va nous manquer comme à tous
les français il nous manquait déjà quand
il a arrêté le jt 13h et c'est vrai que
là il va nous manquer encore plus une
longévité incroyable et jean-pierre
c'est vrai que c'était pas la citer
notre rayon de soleil du trader c'est
notre rayon de soleil quand ils venaient
nous voir c'était notre rayon de soleil
quand on l'avait au téléphone nathalie
sa femme aussi c'est un rayon de soleil
on pense vraiment fort fort à elle qui
s'est battu avec lui jusqu'au bout il
était ces derniers vont vraiment avec
lui tout le temps elle n'a jamais laissé
et elle m'a el madina lake note nathalie
j'ai eu au téléphone avant-hier à me dit
jean pierre lui disait qu'il était à
l'hôpital mais moi touche pas à mon
poste comme à ce que je te sens très
triste aussi la wii très triste parce
que on avait fait un documentaire est
pas très longtemps avec son fils tom est
un amour aussi toute la famille c'est
vraiment débat voilà est qui qui perd
son papa d'une maladie que je connais
bien il est très jeune pour perdre son
papa de cette maladie donc oui ça me
parle aussi parce que voilà j'avais
perdu quelqu'un ma mère a au même âge je
donc j'étais très touché par lui et puis
et puis très touché et très
choqué parce que je ne savais pas qu'il
avait pas bien depuis quelques jours et
comme j'avais une atelier à côté de moi
il ya quelques semaines et qu'elle
m'avait dit j'ai une bonne nouvelle à
t'annoncer il ya plus de métastases sur
le deuxième poumon ça va mieux
trois semaines après j'ai allumé la télé
je vois ça morges cc 1 c'est un choc
gigantesque
les cherry on voulait vous montrer un
extrait absolument incroyable qui a
refait surface sur les réseaux ce
week-end c'est un extrait du
documentaire edouard mon pote de droite
sur l'ancien premier ministre edouard
philippe qui date de 2018 notez bien la
date 2018 s'est passé sur france 3 avec
france 3 c'est un super doc l'a vu à
l'époque secteur en super doc sur france
5 dans l'extrait s'interrogent et se
questionne sur les reproches qu'on
pourrait lui faire plus tard et regardez
il va réussir à prédire ce qui semblait
impensable à l'époque cet extrait a
rendu fou tout le monde depuis tout le
monde appelle edouard philippe claude
alexis
[Rires]
peut-être que dans cinq ans me
reprochera pas avoir
augmenté des efforts
dans la recherche médicale parce qu'il y
aura un virus qu'on n'a pas vu venir tu
vois
tu peux prendre le pari là dessus
peut-être que dans cinq ans quelqu'un
viendra me dire mais vous n'avez pas vu
que les russes ils allaient envahir la
pologne
non mais je dis n'importe quoi je dis
n'importe quoi mais tu vois que tu peux
tu peux faire le pari que dans les dix
ans qui viennent il n'y a pas on n'aura
pas un risque sur notre sécurité
c'est incroyable incroyable ça
franchement
c'est un visionnaire et en plus on a
l'impression qu'il il anticipe en
imaginant mais qu'on a l'impression
qu'il a des infos ce qui a troublé
beaucoup de monde ça fait que je
voudrais dire qu'il ya aucun complotisme
là dedans il assad info
c'est le stratège politique qui
imaginent que dans le domaine de la
médecine et dans le domaine
international on peut pas tout calcul
est donc franchement bravo à lui et quoi
ça lui donne je trouve une stature
vraiment d'homme d'état encore plus
incroyable pour la c6 des rangs c'est
fou et demi siècle à quai et gilles vous
entendiez pas depuis longtemps qu'ils
allaient avoir des problèmes avec avec
vladimir poutine s'est cézanne et qui si
tout le monde dit que c'est fragile et
qu'à un moment ça va péter et beaucoup
de dirigeants aujourd'hui ce reproche de
ne pas avoir pris au sérieux les
avertissements notamment des services
secrets les américains quand même on les
moque souvent mais il avait averti de la
dangerosité du personnage et on n'a pas
pris ça assez au sérieux peut-être qu'on
aurait pu juguler avant l'empêcher je
sais pas mais au moins essayer d'agir
par anticipation ce qu'on n'a pas su y
compris sur l'ukraine parce que ça fait
huit ans que j'ai tant qu en ukraine
dans le donbass il ya des bombardements
et cueillette de séparatisme et c'est la
crimée déjà au sérieux c'est qu'on a
fait tomber les américains ont fait
tomber quasiment tous les dictateurs de
petits pays ou qui n'est pas là bon
celui-là il arrive bien aimé le faire
tomber ça ça ne fait pas tomber un mec
plus gros plateau
milhas sergei et chroniqueur voilà
et sergei et bah écoutez ici
la réaction de 6/2 ortega
avait jeudi il dit dix ils disent
n'importe quoi les deux citoyens invités
eux
ni que de la merde ok on est premier en
armée européenne mais la russie n'est
pas l'europe et ils font ils ont une
très forte armée cantera l'autre ex
espion et
c6 est vrai de vrai s'imagine bien qu'en
aucun cas ils osent ouvrir sa bouche
comme ça car indirect il se ferait tuer
car les agents secrets par les autres
savants secret des autres espions qu'est
ce que vous répondez sergei bajeux leurs
pendants rien du tout
ils attaquent des personnalités comme
nous
je ne peux plus aller manger au
restaurant je peux plus aller manger au
restaurant a dénoncé dans paris je suis
peut-être le seul espion qui possèdent
des documents qui le prouvent
d'assurbanque parce que j'ai eu la
décision du ciseau la ville de moscou
qui m'a convoqué parce que j'ai fait un
procès à au service d'espionnage ça ça
fait un buzz puisque je leur demandais
mon diplôme d' espions et donc il ya un
juge qui m'a convoqué avec le
représentant du service d'espionnage et
a dit expliquez vous et après la fois
hélas elle a fait une décision sur cinq
pages et 10 devant chez moi se présente
monsieur giraud 9 qui déclare être un
ancien du kgb je constate qu'il est
d'accord je constate qu'il a fait ses
études à l'institut encore pop parce que
nous ont fourni les documents je
constate qu'il a obtenu son diplôme et
la cité et cite le diplôme je constate
qu'ils apprennent à travailler à
l'étranger et compris en france c'est la
décision de justice la décision justice
se termine qu'en dise mais
il faut bien préciser que j'ai fait un
serment solennel au kgb qui était le
bras armé du parti communiste de l'union
soviétique en décembre en 1991 le kgb a
cessé d'exister le parti communiste
s'est s'est désisté et l'urss a cessé
d'exister c'est à partir de là tout mais
tout est caduque par rapport à tout ce
que j'ai signé je peux dire ce que je
veux ça après ils ont dit même les
anciens n'ont pas le droit de lui dire
c'est leur problème c'est pas le mien
mois le pays à qui j'ai et le kgb à qui
j'ai prêté le serment solennel n'existe
plus la capeb et